ce sont deux événements qui vont nous
intéresser à présent pour la suite de ce
cette suite le city raid du 17 avril
avec christine her bonsoir une
responsable du pôle jeunesse à montigny
le bretonneux il avait la main bonsoir à
vous vous êtes délégué à la jeunesse à
montigny forcément maire-adjointe nous
allons parler du 6-2 tout à l'heure
cette initiative citoyenne qui permet
aux 10-13 ans de découvrir leur ville
les institutions également un rallye qui
se déroule à travers toute la france
plusieurs étapes et puis une grande
finale à paris
on le verra dans un instant autre rendez
vous c'est la course du printemps 33e
édition
c'est un rendez vous à la fois sportif
et familial c'est à voisins le
bretonneux toujours piloté par le centre
alfred de vigny et dont le chargé de
l'événementiel est avec nous ce soir
bonsoir
je disais tout à l'heure c'était un
rendez vous à la fois sportif et
familial parce qu'il y à des courses qui
s'adresse aux plus jeunes
avant de parler du grand rendez vous du
15 km on va s'intéresser aux courses
pour les plus accessibles mettre
d'accord disons qu après midi c'est
réservé à ovi chinois avec la grande
ville chinoise aux années collèges et
aux écoles du cp au cm2 il ya une course
par catégorie avec un classement par par
tranche d'âge donc ce sont des courses
de combien de kilomètres alors pour les
plus petits c'est 820 mètres pour les un
peu plus grand c'est mille soixante
mètres sans permettre pour les humbles
oui mais je peux vous dire qu'il est bon
ils ont pas tellement de notions ils ont
pas l'entraînement spécifique qui ils
vont au bout d'eux-mêmes tout de suite
c'est un peu comme des chiens fous et
gérer on a plus de 2 d'attention à
l'arrivée avec le service médical que
pour les anciens qui savent ce que
j'irais quand les enfants partent
travailler là bas ils sont à fond tout
de suite quoi donc c'est faux les un peu
les canaliser au départ d'ailleurs on a
on a des éducateurs d'ailleurs qu'il est
bloqué un petit peu au départ c'est
prévu donc ces courses qui s'adresse aux
plus jeunes aux écoles ce sont
uniquement les écoliers de la ville de
saint quentin en yvelines c'est
important aussi
comme il est encore possible de s'y
inscrire oui tout à fait jusqu'à samedi
soir 18h il ya des permanences
organisées au gymnase des pyramides sont
les inscriptions justement parce que
cette édition sa 63e édition s'annonce
bien disons que on espère que le beau
temps sera là au moins pas de pluie on a
choisi le dimanche de pâques je dirais
il ya beaucoup de courses organisées sur
les yvelines c'était le seul jour où
y'avait personne donc on a dit banco et
pour parler un petit peu des récompenses
je pense que cette année les gens
voteraient surpris agréablement
on a fait faire quelque chose de très
joli par un chocolatier avec des
maquettes en sérigraphie if you're a pas
de coupe cette année quelques bonbons
chocolats j'ai vu les maquettes et et
chaque personne qui viendra sa petite
s'applique médaille en chocolat les
enjeux mais pas pour les 4e et ça sera
pour les premiers il faudra bien monté
sommes sur le podium est forcément vous
parler de la météo annoncent plutôt du
froid une courbe du printemps qui se
déroule dans ce climat là c'est habituel
il est habitué mais fier de moi si tu as
perdu autant vraiment mais bon nous on
croise les doigts cela puis quoi le le
je veux dire l'ennemi public numéro 1
c'est la pluie quoi qui fait un peu
froid pour courir c'est bien agréable
on en vient ce parcours de 15 km c'est
un parcours labellisés on y compte pour
le challenge des cibles et oui c'est une
course importante pour les sportifs et
les coureurs presque presque
professionnelle puisque ce qui court le
plus souvent
quelles sont les nouveautés est ce qu'il
ya des nouveautés cette année bah disons
que le parcours a été tellement apprécié
les années précédentes ça fait trois ans
qu'on est sur ce parcours donc tous les
coureurs nous ont dit qu'il était
vraiment idéal pour faire un temps pour
se faire plaisir il ya 80% dans les bois
donc c'est très agréable dire les gens
aiment beaucoup ces parcours nature et
je pense que bon bah on va pas changer
quelque chose qui plaît donc
on essaie toujours d'améliorer un petit
peu il y aura une belle animation au
départ mais je peux pas en dire plus
donc surtout pas voir la maquette des
récompenses on ne peut pas annoncer faut
que les gens viennent je pense que
j'espère qu'ils les gens qui courent le
dimanche matin mutuellement viendront
faire leur petit footing avec nous et
après pour aller faire un pierrot pas de
famille encore on conçoit tout à fait
que le dimanche de pâques c'est et
privilégient pour la famille mais bon ça
empêche pas d'aller se dégourdir un peu
les jambes le matin nature nature
ça veut dire qu on ne passe pas par la
ville au début on est bien obligé on
part du gymnase du pyramid ont fait un
petit bain de foule par le centre ville
et après on part vers la croix du bois
pour ceux qui connaissent et on est dans
les bois tout le temps est ce que cette
course fédère au delà justement de 50
ans et oui puisque c'est une course qui
compte pour le challenge du département
voit la rue basse disons que
prioritairement ceux ci champlain des
yvelines mais bon on essaie d'élargir la
publicité on s'inscrit sur tous les
supports de communication des sportifs
des coureurs et on espère en touche et à
chaque fois de plus en plus quoi bon
toutes les courses alentours à partir du
mois de novembre sur les quatre châteaux
ou là où on voit des flyers enfin bon on
communique beaucoup on était au
semi-marathon de rambouillet dimanche
pour donner des jeux dire voilà on
essaye vraiment de de la valoriser bon
même en général les coureurs dont ils
savent les courses qui qu'ils aiment
qu'ils préfèrent et en général ils les
cibles sur l'année quoi se classer la
33e édition gold inc
les séances doivent le coach est dans le
ragot viennent régulièrement comment se
déroulent les saint quentinois peut-être
si la vie si noir pendant deux jours
bien sur cette course essaoui a aussi
loin dans dix ans des éditions
précédentes un gros club sur saint
quentin davies et le à saint-quentin
bien sûr qu'ils viennent en équipe et
qui ont ils sont l'équipe à battre quoi
en fait
donc il ya eu aussi qui est très fort
mais enfin bon ils se tirent une belle
compétition entre coup favori pour la
compréhension de la cette année le à 50
ans est votre pronostic
je pense et cette année on aura un
échauffement musicale fait sous le
podium à partir de 9h30 à un
échauffement pour tous les coureurs et
ce sera ce week end